foreign
[Applause]
what did you want to be when you grew up
footballer an actress a doctor
well when I was a little girl whenever I
was asked a question my answer was
pretty much always the same
when I grow up I want to become a man
to my logic that was the only way I
could live a life free from the
suffocating restrictions that women in
my birth country of Iran were forced to
enjoy
I'm not quite sure where this line of
thinking started from but a particularly
hot Summer's afternoon comes to mind I
was nine years old and along with my
family as we did on every summer holiday
we had traveled to the north of Iran to
a little seaside village called champion
for as long as I remember some of my
best childhood memories are of me
swimming in the Caspian Sea paddling in
its waves and making sand castles on its
gorgeous beaches
all of those lovely memories though were
about to be Rewritten
in the Islamic Republic of Iran when a
girl turns nine years old she has
legally entered Womanhood and that means
having to follow a series of restrictive
rules written by men
there's no the most symbolic of which is
probably the mandatory wearing of the
hijab
that year my mom had to sit me down and
sorrowfully explain
that I was now too old to get into the
water wearing a swimsuit
now that I was nine years old it was
illegal and if I wanted to get into the
water like all the other women I had to
go in fully covered from head to toe I
had to go in wearing a pair of trousers
a long sleeve top and a loose covering
called The Man total cover it all and of
course the head scarf
I still remember the lump in my throat
as I set foot in the water
I could no longer feel the fresh
coolness of the Caspian Sea against my
skin
instead my nawed layers felt itchy and
weird
I can still remember feeling the
watchful eyes of the morality police the
so-called morality police
making sure that me and the other girls
weren't showing too much hair or too
much skin to God forbid arouse the men
it was as if my former freedoms were
washing away with every tide and flow of
the water
next I'm deep in the water
I was a good swimmer but my layers were
so heavy and restrictive I tried to gas
for air but my head scarf kept blocking
my face the tides were pulling me
further and further out
I could see my mom and dad on the beach
I tried to call for help but they
couldn't hear me
perhaps my voice was drowned out
by The Roaring engines of the bikes that
the morality police were patrolling the
beaches
the tides continued pulling me further
and further out
and hopelessness started creeping in
next I wake up on the beach
cold wet shivering
it turns out my father had just spotted
my struggles in time and had rushed in
to get me
that was the last time I ever set foot
in my beloved Caspian Sea
growing up in the Islamic Republic of
Iran every day it felt as though I was
going through the same experience but in
different ways and looking at the women
in my life they seem to be going through
the same thing too in different ways and
the older I grew the further out the
tides of Oppression Injustice inequality
felt like they were pulling me in
wherever I turned shame fear and
specially hopelessness wherever present
women in Iran are second-class citizens
they have almost no access when it comes
to some of the most basic rights like
divorce custody of children and even
travel
they have no legal protection against
sexual harassment and domestic violence
they're not allowed to sing in public or
have sex outside of marriage and they're
only allowed to show their face and hand
in public
in the 20 years or so since I almost
drowned nothing has changed Iranian
women have been adrift in a vast sea of
Oppression their only way out for those
who could is to leave themselves at the
mercy of people's Smugglers set out on
dangerous Journeys in Hope of finding
safety in a land far away
to me age 12 along with my mom and my
baby sister we escaped Iran and after
years of living in refugee camps across
Europe sleeping rough and being at the
mercy of some very very Dutchy people
Smugglers we finally found Safe Haven
here in the UK
for my friends and family who stayed
behind there was little Hope for Change
and so when in September last year 22
year old masagina amini stepped out of
the Metro onto the bustling streets of
Tehran there was little reason to expect
a change to the status quo
the same way that it's happened to my
own mother and many other women I know
Masa was arrested by the so-called
morality police because in their opinion
she was showing more hair than they
deemed acceptable
three days later Masa died in police
custody
this time though something changed
thanks to the power of social media and
the brave journalist working hard on the
ground the news of Masters killing
wasn't drowned out in the regime's
Relentless propaganda
in the same way that the unjust killing
of George Floyd ignited their black
lives matter movement the unjust killing
of Masa amini ignited the biggest
anti-regime protest across Iran since
the formation of the Islamic Republic in
1979.
for the first time in decades women in
Iran are finally daring to defy their
strict morality laws in a fight for
equality and dignity they're taking off
their headscarves burning them in
bonfires and some are cutting off their
hair
they're chanting Zan zendegi Azadi women
life freedom
Furious crowds are calling for democracy
for freedom of speech for freedom of
expression whilst many others are
calling for the fall of the supreme
leader Ali Harmony
is Iran's spiritual leader and has the
final say over all government matters
for the first time in a very very long
time there seems to be hope in the air
hope that perhaps change in Iran is
possible
and that's exactly why the Crackdown has
been so brutal and deadly
these are the faces of the protesters
who fought for freedom
but will not live
to see it
since the protest began
nearly five months ago
around 500 people have been killed
nearly 80 of those children
around 18 000 protesters have been
arrested and there are reports of
psychological physical and sexual
torture in prisons
there has been a series of hasty trials
forced confessions and public executions
of the protesters
the authoritarian regime of Iran is
clearly desperate to kill any and or
hope because they know that for as long
as we remain hopeless will resign to
their oppression and Injustice
but as history has shown over and over
again the Light Of Hope emerges from the
depth of Darkness
hope is angry it's defiant hope is
dangerous hope is standing in its
grounds on the streets of Iran chanting
women life freedom hope is in political
prisons biding its time sustaining those
in shackles
hope has now spread to the four corners
of my bath country
as a journalist I can't travel to Iran
but as my sisters in Tehran Mash had
Shiraz baluchistan
all over Iran have done I too
I'm going to cut my hair to show my
solidarity with the movement
[Music]
thank you
thank you yes
this hair for too long has been
intertwined with religion and politics
but I say with my sisters in Iran no
more
and I say with them
women
to reclaim our rights
life for the lives unjustly taken
freedom
for the liberation of my people
[Applause]
I stand here with my hair in my hand in
Hope of her future
where no little girl has to wish you
were a man
because she's she's terrified that she
might drown every day
[Music]
yes the Crackdown is brutal
and yes there might not be a solution
inside yet
but the only thing that can help create
and sustain one is Hope
sorry
the only thing that can help create and
sustain one is Hope
and every single one of us can take a
step and play our part
I'm standing here speaking to you now
many non-iranians and Iranians outside
of Iran have been signing petitions
going to protest putting pressure on
their governments so that in turn they
put pressure on the Iranian regime and
government
for the past few months I've been
speaking to protesters inside of Iran
and they tell me how much it matters to
them that we on the outside stay
informed and engaged
so let's try our best to make certain
that those of us on the shore let those
at Sea know that we see them that we
hear their cries
thank you for taking a step towards a
future where Freedom Is Not Just a Dream
but a reality
not just for women
but for everyone
and not just in Iran
but everywhere thank you
[Applause]